you end your rally speeches now with
music in the background and you start
with we are a nation in Decline and this
is a very different America than what it
was when you left it as president two
and a half years ago and I can point to
the Border I can look at laws all over
the country uh defund dismantle no bail
laws uh we've given up energy
Independence we're importing oil from
Venezuela and and OPEC and they're all
right nowhere to believe that and we now
see two-thirds of our country live in
paycheck to paycheck you see some people
now cashing in their retirement just so
they can make ends meet others are
putting you know Bare Necessities on
credit cards I'll mention this in Iowa
because I I have you know a radio show
with 720 stations Farmers call me the
cost of fertilize us three times what it
used to be the cost of seed is twice
what it used to be and if you can get
the parts to repair your equipment you
know it's four times what it used to be
how you know how I've never seen it this
bad or this the decline this
precipitously
so we were energy independent think of
it three years ago and
and what people
what people don't know is that we have I
call it Liquid Gold because it's gold
it's better than gold we have liquid
gold under our feet more than any other
Nation more than Saudi Arabia more than
Russia we're energy independent within
six months we would have been energy
dominant and we were going to sell
energy to Europe and lots of other
places and we're going to make so much
money doing it because it's such a big
world you know it's such a big business
it's all encompassing and that's what
started the inflation I mean the energy
we stopped Drilling and all of a sudden
the gasoline's going up to five six
dollars a gallon in a car for a car and
just horrible things were happening and
it it happened but we were going to pay
off debt we were going to reduce taxes
further we gave you the biggest tax cut
in the history of our country bigger
than the Ronald Reagan Texas and the
biggest
and you know I think more importantly
Sean they gave you the biggest
regulation Cuts that's why we had more
jobs than we ever had before we've never
had anything close and we did all of
that and then to end that but we were
going to pay off debt we were going to
get the debt because the money is so big
it's so massive you look at Saudi Arabia
the money they have no Nations ever had
anything like it and we have more than
they have we're going to pay off debt we
were going to get the energy prices down
we're going to get interest rates down
it it was like we had something going
that and within six months we would have
been dominant because we would have
taken over Europe we would have
literally been supplying the energy to
Europe and we would have made a fortune
we would have paid down the debt we
would have cut the taxes it was going to
be so beautiful hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else